hey youtubers is Charlie this week was
the orphan black finale it was amazing
but as of me making this video they have
not confirmed it for season 3 the
episode was constructed to achieve
maximum WTF from the Phantom if it does
not get season 3 I feel like a lot of
clever shows do that nowadays where they
engineer themselves so that networks
feel obligated to renew them even if
ratings aren't quite as good as they
want them to be just to clarify I do
think it'll be renewed for season 3 and
they'll probably going to make an
official announcement pretty soon if you
don't notice BBC America laid a ton of
graphics bugs on top of the broadcast
with notes about Tatiana maslany being
nominated for a ton of awards networks
just don't do that for shows that they
don't believe in so it just goes to show
you the BBC America really is pulling
for from black season 3 but let's start
digging into the finale so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but I'm going to start with my top 5
moments then I'll do an overall review
of season 2 and then I'll talk about
season 3 so here we go number 5 Sarah
turns herself into dyad this is a very
very cold open I don't remember meeting
dr. Nealon before but he's basically
like the new leekie the new sinister
looking person with mysterious
intentions almost everyone at dyad is
sinister and mysterious though so that's
not saying a lot Delphine is like the
only one that wears her emotions on her
sleeve she's pretty easy to read and I
don't count Cosima is dyad because she's
kind of a double agent for clone Club I
think Sarah made the right choice
turning herself in before Cal and Mrs S
jumped in and had a chance to contact
their insiders there wasn't really a
better way to get to Keira in a hurry I
was a little blown away when they
full-on tried to take one of her ovaries
because of all the side projects that
leekie teased earlier this season like
the artificial womb I actually thought
the show is going to show us some sort
of gruesome Frankenstein babymaker we
did end up getting a Frankenstein moment
later in the episode but I felt like
Sarah's escape was one of the most
curable moments in the episode like her
escaping from Rachel I like the way they
use Keira scenes to kind of highlight
the science and the more technical
aspects of the story too like using cure
to explain the fire extinguisher
mechanism as well as what's going to
become the story of season 3 with the
dr. Moreau stuff Keira wind science so
hard in this episode number 4 Cal and
Mrs S revealed their inside men I was
totally surprised by the Paul and Marian
reveals I read some interviews with
Michelle Forbes a couple of weeks ago
after her character debuted and she just
said that Mary
would be getting crazier and crazier all
the way into the finale I wouldn't call
her crazy but Marion is like the
neolutionist analog of mrs. s they're
both very caring nurturing mothers but
they sit on two sides of the fence
season three is going to explain those
allegiances a little bit better but I
feel like as of the end of the episode
were meant to apply that mrs. s is in
bed with the military Paul and project
castor all the male clones and just to
explain when Mrs S told Callie didn't
know his mythology castor is one of the
twin sons of Leda she was a Greek
princess she was seduced by Zeus who
appeared to her as a swan and
impregnated her that same night she also
slept with her husband King tonightís
and she ended up giving birth to four
children two girls and two boys so the
girls were Helen of Troy and Clemens
drew and the boys were castor and pollux
because Leda slept with Zeus in her
mortal husband castor was born of the
husband's mortal line and Pollux was
born of Zeus's you may be more familiar
with castor and Pollux by their Latin
name together they're known as Gemini as
in Gemini twins it's just a high-minded
metaphor for the way the military
compartmentalized project Leda into
project castor and project dyad Paul is
obviously working with the military and
because Marian said that she's trying to
learn which other big group was trying
to influence the cloning projects and
then it cut to the military in the
episode I think we can assume that
they're that other big group they're
probably going to take the antagonist
role that the proletheans had in season
two they're just going to be like the
other side of the coin if it wasn't
clear Paul was mrs. s's Inside Man and
Marian was cows she was that person
trying to hack him on the dark web
marian seemed like she wanted to help
clone club but just like we learned a
lot more about mrs. s that wasn't super
flattering in season two I think the
same is going to happen in season three
with the Marian character but I'm so
happy Michelle Forbes is gonna stay on
board number three Sarah shoots Rachel
in the eye as horrible as it was I was
kind of happy to see her take it in the
face if you apply TV logic though she is
not dead she'll be back next season with
an eyepatch that pencil didn't look like
it penetrated deep enough into her skull
to cause brain damage but she's
definitely not gonna keep that eye in
case you don't watch Doctor Who there
was this character called Madame
Kovarian that rachel is starting to
resemble more and more she was just a
really evil person with an eyepatch I
actually felt a little bit of sympathy
for whenever Duncan committed suicide he
was like her father but at this point in
the narrative
she's eroded all of our goodwill
the other really funny thing about this
whole scene was that Kira had drawn a
picture of the fire extinguisher and she
would have had to drawn that before she
played science with Cosima they're
starting to blur the line between
intuition and full-on foresight it's
like Kira is reading matrix code while
all the other characters are stuck
inside the construct and now that Gracie
is pregnant with Helena's baby there
will be another potential Kira all the
clones are different though so it's hard
to tell what special abilities that baby
might manifest the real take away though
is that Rachel is going to be back next
season and twice as mean number 2 the
island of dr. Moreau I love the way they
connected Casillas Buckminster Fuller
golden ratio speech to Duncan's research
and the end reveal of all the male
clones just like an endlessly repeating
pattern in nature and they're all stuck
on this island of Monsters I think in
reality the island is going to turn out
to be wherever the military is
performing all their experiments but I'm
not expecting them to show an actual
island I don't think they're gonna take
the metaphor that literally even though
dr. Neelam was introduced at the
beginning of the episode I don't think
he's the dr. Moreau in this situation I
think that that person is someone we
won't meet until season 3 and then
there's all the people in the topside
organization that Marian teased most of
season 2 has been spent learning about
the prolethean agenda versus the diet
agenda and now we have to learn about
the military's agenda but I think based
on the way they were teased they're just
trying to create an infinitely renewable
source of bodies for their army right
now I'm picturing someone like the
Stephen Lang character from Avatar being
in charge like the military big bad he
played Colonel Quaritch you know someone
who doesn't see themselves as evil but
literally will step on people with giant
mech feet whenever they get in the way I
also think that it was implied that the
military has a lot more control over
project caster than the diet had over
there cloning experiments so it seems
like clone club is really gonna have to
raise the bar if they're going to
infiltrate them Paul will always have a
soft spot for Sara so they'll at least
have him on the inside
Hellena it seems though is someone Paul
is all too happy to sacrifice they're
probably going to use her the same way
that proletheans tried to do to just
grow more Kira's basically and my number
one moment obviously mark is the male
clone and there are a lot of him this
was the major reveal of the episode of
all the surprises we got this was
probably my most unexpected I actually
thought we'd see another version of Tony
whenever he turned around and Marian's
basement I think as we meet more mark
clones next season they'll display the
same level
diversity of personalities that saris
clones - although I guess technically
Rachel was the first clone you know like
the beta test that just means that mark
and Gracie story is gonna get folded
back into clone clubs at a certain point
and if you think about the relationship
between Sarah Kira and Cal I think that
Mark and Gracie's story is going to be a
little bit like that Sarah doesn't care
anything about the dyad or the
proletheans stuff she just wants to keep
cure safe and live out their lives in
peace so I think that Mark and Gracie
are just going to be on the run in
season 3 you know just like Sarah and
Kira even if Mark isn't just a carbon
copy male version of Sarah I think he's
going to turn out to be a good person
the creators actually talked a lot about
Mark's character he said that he was
modeled after a world war two soldiers
which kind of makes me wonder if the
military's been experimenting with clone
since the 50s all the project Leda stuff
was from the 70s but if that came from
the military they had to start somewhere
we'll probably learn that whole story
over the course of season 3 you know
when the military started and what their
master plan is seeing Charlotte at the
end to kind of made me excited at the
thought that we'll see more Tony's next
season you know more versions of Sarah
so overall I thought the finale was a
rock solid a you know the story was
amazing but I also had to give it a lot
of bonus points for technical
achievements for example Tatiana maslany
had to perform that dance party scene a
bunch of times for each clone and they
had to digitally add them together to
give us clone Club just getting those
few minutes of footage plight took weeks
to complete and editing I know I
mentioned it during my top five moments
but Tatiana maslany gets nominated for a
crazy number of acting words every year
I hope she ends up winning at least one
Emmy for season 2 being able to create
all those unique personalities and jump
back and forth between them while they
shoot is just amazing most actors find
it difficult to play one character so
that's actually where we need to talk
about Mark's character because he's
obviously going to have to play a lot of
different versions of that clone the
actor's name is Ari Mellon he's the one
playing mark the creator said that he
didn't know he was playing a clone
whenever they cast him and they actually
intended to kill him in episode 6 but
they liked him so much that they
expanded his part shows do that all the
time
it's like on Game of Thrones the
producers gave the Shay character a much
bigger part they just liked to perform
it so much so they changed the story to
accommodate that I think it's a good
omen for all the male clones we'll see
in season 3 but I'm not expecting the
same level of performance that Tatiana
maslany gives but I'm looking forward to
Ari the actor proving me wrong I have to
say the most fun I have watching the
shows whenever
all the clones are together on screen so
if he can do a male clone version of
clone club that's as fun as the female
clone club season 3 is going to be
amazing a lot of time I don't even care
about the science aspects of the show
but I do love the way they weave
existentialism and comedy into it it
makes it a lot easier to digest all the
genetics talk the science of the show is
amazing but I really just watch it for
Tatiana maslany and all the other
characters I don't have a whole lot more
to say about season 3 other than we're
shifting focus from the proletheans to
the military it's all about the Gemini
twins two sides of the story so the
military is just going to be the other
side of that next year and like I said
their plan I can't wait very long before
making a season 3 announcement and on
the off chance that they do not renew it
I sent out all of my digital hugs to you
guys after you have time to process the
episode I highly recommend you start
catching up on Doctor Who because series
8 is premiering in August and I'm going
to be doing a ton of videos for it and
it's going to be awesome be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff I'm not
going to be doing an orphan black Q&A
tomorrow or anything so if you have any
questions about the season or this
episode just post them in the comments
below
but right now click here to watch all my
other season 2 videos and click here to
learn all about Doctor Who series 8
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you tonight
high fives
you